foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from Buckingham Palace our top
story
a royal Walkabout before the king
pledges to serve people and Country at
his coronation
air apparent no more tomorrow the
pageantry and ceremony in Westminster
Abbey as he is officially crammed
it's like symbolizing a new era for the
country I would like to bring down the
mountain to watch and all people coming
together
as across the land young and old prepare
to witness the first spectacle of its
kind for 70 years
also tonight the local election results
which suggests the kissed armor is on
course to be the next prime minister
after more than seven million confirmed
deaths the World Health Organization
declares an end to the global covert
emergency
Panic on the Underground as part
smash their way out of their tube
Carriage fearing a fire
thus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
foreign
Buckingham Palace tomorrow a new king
will be crowned for so long The Heir
Apparent King Charles will formally be
named Monarch in a solemn ceremony at
Westminster Abbey but before that yet
another rehearsal a reception for world
leaders and foreign dignitaries and this
afternoon an unexpected Walkabout to
Greek crowds on the mall many who camped
out overnight our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock has tonight's first report
they'd come to see him so when he went
to see them this was the reaction
[Applause]
s
congratulations
how did he seem to you really friendly
yeah he seemed really nice nervous at
all do you think no
I didn't think so
and for one Frenchman the British
royalty have really left a mark it's for
the safer Camilla
the safer of Elizabeth II and the safer
of the this of Elizabeth
on either side crowds lined The Mao and
Royals Walked the Line The Prince and
Princess of Wales taking time to chat
and thank the fans have you camped out
here I'm going to be here tonight yes I
am
there's not much sleeping going on
yeah
if you say that for anything like this
before yes Jubilee did you yes before
you go by do you know you're prepared I
didn't this is my first time I cannot
believe I'm meeting you just over 2 000
people have invites a guest list recast
to reflect modern society
how do you think you'll feel when you're
sat inside the Abbey I do think I will
be looking to wipe back at eye a tear or
or something like that because it is
something that's a you know amazing
experience to be involved in with one
day to go one final rehearsal for the
king and queen consort complete with
robes and regalia
and then to greet their guests the pool
of a royal ceremony bringing together a
who's who of global politics what's been
exciting is to see leaders coming from
the four corners of the world to
celebrate this and for all of our 56
members of the Commonwealth representing
2.5 billion people
there are a lot of views about this
coronation the king and the monarchy but
take a step back and this remains a
hugely significant moment in British
history and one that very few will have
seen before they've been waiting days
for the coronation but the Kings waited
longer than any other British monarch
and his time has almost come Laura
bundock Sky News
well while that ceremony is unfolding
inside the Abbey tomorrow outside
thousands of police officers will be
deployed today the head of the Met
police suggested that tolerance that any
disruption would be extremely low but
while environmental protester told Sky
News that with Millions watching it was
the ideal time to spread the climate
message Sherman Freeman Powell reports
hundreds have already arrived and
thousands more are on the way it will be
one of the biggest ceremonial events
ever seen on The Streets of London and
the largest Security operation we've got
more than 300 VIPs Prime Ministers
presidents royalty from across the Globe
coming to our city will have hundreds of
thousands of people along the ceremonial
procession route and the job of the
police site is a really hard one to keep
us safe to keep us secure but to let
everyone to have a good time and I'm
really confident the preparation the
planning has been fantastic and
exemplary as you can see behind me some
of the hard-working police taking a
while deserve break more than a million
people are expected to come to these
streets to celebrate the coronation and
most of them will be peaceful but with
crowds of this size just one incident
could have a huge impact
to ensure iron clad protection on the
king's big day more than 11 000 officers
have been deployed aided by new
legislation which carries up to a year
in jail for anyone tempted to cause
disruption our assessment of the Tipping
Point to say this protest has gone
beyond the reasonable inter being
disruptive and therefore we're going to
intervene it's a much lower tolerance
than it might be on a normal day that's
what this is about but the lower
tolerance approach seems hard to Define
I'm not going to go into every
individual case because it depends on
what's exactly on the ground that day
but it if that is going to fundamentally
obstruct the enjoyment and celebration
for a significant number of people
that's disrupting the events and that
would probably tip us into action
concerning for activists whose main
tactics involve civil disruption which
on Saturday could land them in jail what
is the right time in the right place you
know whenever they say this it's always
why don't you go to the pavement where
nobody can see you and do your little
protest but this is absolutely the right
time look at how many people are here in
Parliament this is the ideal opportunity
police have worked with activists to
provide a space where they can have
their say but the new laws mean they can
protest but not disrupt a controversial
measure the police have to get right as
it's being tested on the day the world
will be watching Shimon Freeman Powell
Sky News
and our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock is with me now Laura a big
moment for the king tomorrow King Keen
to make his mark on the ceremony and on
the monarchy it really is a huge moment
a significant milestone for the British
Monarchy but a really important personal
event for the king as well we had a lot
of pageantry last year for the late
Queen with our Platinum Jubilee and of
course her funeral but what struck me is
the crowds lining the mouth several
people deep in places they're all here
for the king and you've got a real sense
I think that he is looking forward to
this that he is in good spirits as I was
told today when he went out on that
Walkabout to meet some of the crowds
which in itself I think is a significant
moment a moment of informality before
all the formality it's certainly not
something we saw for the Queen's uh
coronation in 1953 or in 37 for the
coronation of her father it was a modern
moment and I think it reflects one of
the big challenges with this coronation
is how to harmonize this ain't ancient
ceremony with the 21st century and we've
seen a bit of that haven't we with the
guest list with the inclusion of other
faiths with women Bishops playing a role
and of course when Rishi sunak a Hindu
prime minister gives a reading from the
Bible so whilst on the one hand you have
this ceremony which would be
recognizable by William the Conqueror
you also have King Charles very much
making his mark on it and of course all
of us will get to see exactly what that
looks like very soon so much precise
planning and preparation is now finally
finished the only thing they have
absolutely no control over is the
weather and frankly who knows what's
going to happen there we shall see we
shall see maybe Wellies might be in
order Laura thank you
now moving away from the coronation it's
the tale of two leaders half today's
local elections prime minister Rishi
sunak admitted that his party's bruising
defeat had been disappointing labor
sakistama looks more likely than ever to
become the next prime minister but
without an overall majority
so with all but a few results now in the
conservatives have now lost more than a
thousand seats the threshold identified
by election analysts as the sign of a
disastrous performance
and strong gains not just for labor but
also for the lib Dems and the green
party as our political editor Beth Rigby
reports
early morning
dway jubilation
[Applause]
time of things to calm labor taking this
Kent Council for the first time
this historic win just the start and
this man overjoyed
today promising a new chapter make no
mistake we are on course for a labor
majority at the next general election
that's his hope and progress across
swathes of Southern England crucial to
hitting it
Swindon another to switch
key marginal territory taken sending a
message to the conservatives change
could be coming unfortunately National
issues just seem to have overwhelmed the
whole situation and hence we've got the
results we've got a brave face for the
PM arriving at party headquarters armed
with sandwiches for staffers but this
very bad and he knows it it's always
disappointing to this hard-working
conservative councilors their friends
their colleagues and I'm so grateful to
them for everything that they've done
but as the day progressed and Counting
continued the results for the
conservatives fell further Dover in Kent
wants a true brexit local elections but
these are a fantastic set of results for
us the spread of our victories overnight
and into today shows actually that we
are making gains in the areas that we
need to be winning for that next general
election
into the West Midlands and pockets of
the north of England father starmus
success Stoke-on-Trent reclaimed a brick
back in the red wall
but a long way to go the conservatives
still with a foothold in Boris Johnson
brexit land holding ground in Warsaw
Dudley and Stockton too
for both sides winning here crucial to
deliver a general election victory
[Music]
any Prospect of that for the
conservatives today dashed nationally we
haven't been helped I think there's been
difficulties and I think the party needs
to reflect on some of the losses that
we've had
[Laughter]
bath Devon to decorum sorry to Stratford
on Avon safe Southern Heartland smashed
liberal Democrat leader Ed Davies
celebrating in Windsor and maidenhead a
once true blue Borough
three two one
now calling time on Tory rule I've been
saying for a long time now the liberal
Democrats are the challenges to the
conservatives across the blue wall seats
in the south of England and Nazi in a
few other places too millions of votes
counted the results are in and these
local elections suggest that circus
starmer is on course to become the next
prime minister it's an incredible
achievement for the labor leader but he
still has a mountain to climb if he
wants to win an outright majority
because these results suggest that we're
heading for a hung Parliament with labor
the largest party
are you facing a Wipeout prime minister
the results speak for themselves this a
disaster do you reckon you'll be able to
turn this around but the Prime Minister
finding comfort in greeting foreign
leaders at number 10. the coronation and
welcome distraction from his domestic
woes but nothing to celebrate for him
here Beth Rigby Sky News in Westminster
so labor has conquered key Battlegrounds
today and despite what their leader says
Uh there's still much more to do if they
are to gain a majority in the House of
Commons Ed Conway has the story behind
the numbers
well vote 2023 the local elections let's
give you a sense of just how the
complexion of the local authorities
around England have changed and you can
see there's a lot less in the way of
blue than there was previously and one
just way of underlining that is to look
at the share of counselors from each
different major party and what you can
probably make out look this period here
where labor were behind the
conservatives that has now been reversed
labor now the biggest party of local
government as a result of these local
elections well that turns into a general
election Victory or not that is a big
question but certainly what's not under
question is how bad a night it has been
for the conservative party this is just
showing you a dial showing you the level
of performance and they've gone down
down down down by more than a thousand
seats more than a thousand councilors
losing for the conservative party how
about for the labor party or similar
things similar exercise except this time
of course they are up in net terms up
into what might be considered good
territory there so a good night for
security a good election for kasekistama
but the lib dam is actually going even
beyond that although in numerological
terms it's not quite as much they've
gone well beyond expectations in terms
of the wins the net wins from the
liberal Democrat Party also the green
party's doing brilliantly by compared
with expectations as well add it all up
and this is the House of Commons
projection from Michael Thrasher our
elections analyst showing that if this
was kind of extrapolated onto the next
general election you're talking about
298 uh seats for the labor party that
would make them the biggest party in
Parliament but still short of the 326
that seats they would need to win an
overall majority
let's go live to Downing Street now and
our political editor Beth Rigby and Beth
um just how much more likely is it now
that we have a new occupant in the
building behind you next year
well Jillian for months the national
polls have suggested that there will be
a change of government at the next
general election with the Tories
trailing labor hugely and these local
elections are now put in Flesh on the
bones that prediction being borne out we
were looking at three different areas
three different strands three different
stories in these local elections one
could Rishi sunak contain the losses too
could the live Dems really take them on
in the blue wall and three of course the
biggest narrative if you like is
kirstama heading to become the next
prime minister based on extrapolating
out these local election results and we
do have plenty of clarity tonight with
the conservatives a simply awful night
my understanding was the worst case
scenario was for them was 700 seats lost
they've gone over a thousand I mean it
really is their worst nightmare coming
true losses up up and down the country
with all parties taking bites out of
them and for Rishi sunak in number 10
tonight he must be thinking I'm not
going to be coming back through this
door at the next general election they'd
hoped to close the gap on labor being
touched and distance that just hasn't
been borne out and it's largely down not
just to labor but the liberal Democrats
they've had a barnstorming night beyond
their wildest expectations seat gains of
over 400 to put it into context we
thought 150 they would be doing well and
would be looking into threaten the
conservatives at a general election some
of those Tory shires that are lib Dem
face and that's the Battleground they've
done far better than that and then we
come to labor and kirstarma solid
progress a good night but sharing the
Limelight a bit with the liberal
Democrats one a very senior labor figure
saying to me tonight that they were
great results not just because of the
numbers of seats but the place is the
key Battlegrounds that kirstarma has
taken also saying that it's unbelievable
to them that the Tories exceeded their
thousand losses but in reality the fat
remains that kierstama while it looks
more likely now based on these results
that he will be heading to number 10 as
potentially the next prime minister he
is not as it stands going to be doing
that on the terms of Tony Blair back in
97 where he had that Landslide win at
the moment it's looking like labor are
heading to be the largest party but a
hung Parliament and that leaves
kierstama quite frankly with plenty of
work to do in the next year to try to
convince more voters to come over to him
okay Beth thank you very much for the
moment
so a Wipeout for the conservatives and
relative success for labor but was this
an election fought on local issues
driven by weariness of the government or
enthusiasm for the alternative Sky's
Nick Martin spoke to those who voted and
many who didn't in Buxton in Derbyshire
to find out
foreign
there are some areas where labor had to
do well to prove they're on the comeback
Buxton is one of those places
[Applause]
labor gained seven seats here the
conservatives lost six it's not the
runaway Victory labor would have liked
but it's a win for them before the
election no single party was in overall
control in this area although labor did
have the majority of seats and speaking
to people in this town there's
definitely a sense of apathy even
weariness towards the conservatives but
labor know that support for them isn't a
sure-run thing either
there's a lot of apathy here Charis and
Daryl they decided not to vote this time
nothing ever comes of what they say
anyway in the first place really does it
so yeah it's a bit sad all that wasn't
it because you could take an active part
you could put your cross on the box you
could see like I want you in I want you
out
I just don't really think it makes much
of a difference so nothing would have
sort of spurred you on to going well you
know what I need to vote no not really
to be honest yeah no
so how did you vote none of the above
I've spoiled paper deliberately so
you've got your postal vote you've got
your pencil out and you just wrecked it
yeah to make a point yes and what is
that point that you're trying to make
don't want any of them
but those people who did vote like
Rachel who's voted for all the main
parties in the past says she wants
something new now obviously the current
government isn't working as it is
um you know with the cost of living
everything's going up isn't it and as a
a parent of a young child as well I
worry about the future and how he's
going to grow up
um so yeah just for change really
and the voters of Buxton could give us a
glimpse of what might happen during the
general election Dawn voted liberal
Democrats this time you don't like
conservatives at all I don't think that
they are
um
thinking about people that are
struggling to have no money that are
really really struggling on the
breadline and the labor I'm a bit
disappointed with Kirsten do you think
that would sort of extend to a general
election the way you feel in a general
election I would feel like voting labor
to get conservatives out
so it's a bit of a tactical vote
these semi-rural areas have suffered
with Rising fuel costs and the lack of
affordable housing and the politics here
is finally balanced Nick Martin Sky News
Buxton
now more than three years after
countries around the world locked down
to slow the spread of covid-19 today
came a significant announcement
scientists at the World Health
Organization say the virus no longer
presents a global Health Emergency as
our science correspondent Thomas Moore
reports yeah kovid turned our lives
upside down but after three years three
months and five days the global Health
Emergency is finally officially over
this is a moment for celebration at
another level
this is a moment for reflection
19 has left
and continues to live
deep scars on our world
it's a hugely symbolic moment the
pandemic overwhelmed hospitals turned
cities into ghost towns and challenged
so much of what we thought we knew about
Society but the virus is no longer the
threat it was no country has been spared
by the virus those in darker colors have
been affected the worst according to the
World Health Organization there have
been more than 765 million confirmed
cases of covid almost seven million
people are known to have died though
it's likely the real total is closer to
20 million so why call and end to the
pandemic emergency now well it is partly
the virus the original Wuhan strain and
the virulent Alpha and Delta variants
caused most of the mortality since the
Omicron Family took over in January last
year deaths have declined the version of
the virus we see now is highly
infectious but less likely to cause
severe disease and of course there is
the vaccine with more than 13 billion
doses given up to the end of April
Khalid is on his fifth dose convinced
the virus is still a threat I don't
think the pandemic's gone personally and
it's just to be safe than sorry other
health problems yeah just to be saved
and sorry
The Who warns Nations must not drop
their guard covered still claims a life
every three minutes and the
shape-shifting virus could yet return in
a new more deadly guys Thomas More Sky
News
police in Serbia have arrested a gunman
suspected of killing eight people and
injuring 13 others in a drive-by
shooting
the attacker initially killed five
people in a village south of the capital
Belgrade before going on to kill three
others in another Village it's the
second mass shooting in less than 48
hours on Wednesday the 13 year old boy
shot dead nine people at a school in
Belgrade before turning himself in
a nurse accused of murdering seven
babies at a Hospital's neonatal unit has
told a court it was a huge unexpected
shock when a baby boy died shortly after
she started her shift
Lucy let B broke down in tears as
prosecutors said she targeted the
children at the Countess of Chester
Hospital between June 2015 and June
2016. she denies murdering seven babies
and attempting to kill 10 others
[Music]
there were frantic scenes at Clapham
common Underground Station in South
London this evening as passengers
smashed the windows of a train believing
it was filling with smoke British
transport police says it's believed that
brake dust which is often confused with
burning and smoke got into the carriage
and caused the Panic there were no
reports of any injuries
well let's return now to what will be a
hugely significant day the coronation of
the first Monarch for 70 years the royal
family and those involved in the
ceremony have rehearsed the moment for
several weeks tomorrow it happens for
real
at 7 30 a.m guests will begin arriving
at Westminster Abbey
the king's procession will depart from
Buckingham Palace at 10 20.
arriving outside the Abbey's West door
shortly before the service begins at
11AM
the king will be crowned around halfway
through the ceremony
then at one o'clock the new king and
queen will depart
in a coronation procession that will
take around 45 minutes to return to
Buckingham Palace
and finally at 2 30
they'll be joined by members of the
royal family on the palace balcony and
along with tens of thousands on the mall
will be treated to a military fly past
or Millions will be watching and a poll
for Sky News suggests two out of three
people will hold their own celebrations
tomorrow that's a lot of Bunting and
warm beer and for some who lived through
the last ceremony in 1953 a chance to
reflect on how much has changed
ashnaharanag reports
it is a welcome coincidence that some of
those who live down this road remember
the last time it happened
Cynthia is expecting a more toned down
celebration to the one she watched aged
23. nonetheless she'll be tuning in from
the crack of dawn oh it was lovely you
know the queen was so pretty
she was in those age you know they'll be
so very different there was more Pomp
and ceremony in the 1953 one don't you
think so your family right Ken says it
will be nostalgic but not in all the
ways he'd like I suppose you know if I
was a lot not younger I might say
another I would I would like to bring
down the mouth and to watch from all
people coming together we'll get to see
Ken two British monarchs being crowned
in your lifetime what's that like
I'm getting old
they have a semblance of what to expect
but many of us simply don't
the children of lawn Primary School in
Derby are full of expectation and
anticipation it's like symbolizing a new
era for the country and it's everyone's
um just coming together as a country to
watch it I can spend time with my family
and watch the king get crowned for the
country to celebrate Tim basically
getting crowned so that's what I'm
really looking forward to
at least they've got the necessary
attire and plenty of enthusiasm
these seamstresses are helping the
nation with that too their machines
haven't stopped churning out the
decorations in the last two months we
have produced 100 kilometers of bunting
which is probably about two or three
times the amount of bunting we would do
in any one year and that's just purely
for the coronation the coronation of one
man big smile all eyes may be on the
capital but much of the nation too will
also be baked in Red White and Blue Ash
Sky News in Cambridgeshire
and be sure to tune in to Sky News at
tomorrow
the full coverage of the build up that
two-hour ceremony and the Fly pass
that's from 7am tomorrow morning
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this on the front of the
express an image of the chair on which
Charles will be crowned their headline
day of Destiny
[Music]
tonight we're going to be joined by
Guardian Economist Zoe Williams and Mary
McLeod former conservative MP and
advisor to the Royal household who's now
chief executive of the charity business
in the community do stay with us for
more
foreign
[Music]